the jurgen experience i found i don't
know if you agree with this
there's uh there were a ton of kids
along the way growing up as i was
building my business
that uh would say oh i'm not into this
i'm not into that
kind of like you described yourself and
they don't do anything because they're
looking for that thing and i would argue
uh do something do [ __ ] something
until you find that thing
yeah i've never been that kid though
i've always been into things i always
was in art or i was into something i was
i always found things that i was
interested in just none of them
seemed like they were normal things that
other people wanted to do for a living
like the path
like a career path but i think that
there's
a lot of people that don't have any
there's no one
there they're not modeling their life
after someone
that they see that they admire someone
that's successful someone that
is doing something that they enjoy and
love sometimes kids have to see that
and if their parents are living a
[ __ ] life and their
neighbors live in a [ __ ] life and
most their family lives a [ __ ] life
they just [ __ ] lay around you know
and then they they seek refuge and drugs
or video games or something that
stimulates them
and video games are a real problem their
real problem you know why because
they're
[ __ ] fun and you don't yeah well i'm
i have a real problem with them
and you you you do them and they're real
exciting but you don't get anywhere
right it's like you could do like like
martial arts right you could learn
jiu jitsu you get obsessed by jiu jitsu
and then
three years later you're you're like an
elite jiu jitsu athlete you're like
you're entering in competitions you're a
purple belt
you're moving up yeah you're doing well
you're thinking like i might be able to
open my own school one day that
confidence yeah if i have a hundred
students and those hundred students are
paying me x amount of dollars per month
i can make a living
holy [ __ ] i can have a this would be
amazing and then you see your jiu jitsu
school and your jiu jitsu instructor has
all these students and drives a mercedes
and he's got a nice family and like
that's the future this way you're doing
something exciting and fun and you don't
or you could just be playing [ __ ]
video games three years later you could
be that same kid
just playing video games waiting for the
next vics whatever the [ __ ]
game is you know next xbox game to come
out
and you're going to waste your time you
you have children
i have i have children and um it's a big
battle
in the house and and my kids i don't
know if you're you're going through this
but my kids
are now saying well dad this guy made
all this money with this video game that
he's saying that's real too so like
that's one in a billion kid
i don't know if it's one in a billion
but you know
look i heard the same argument about
comedy my you know my own parents were
like do you know how few people make it
as a comedian i was like okay
does anybody make it somebody makes it
right they figure out how to do it they
make a living
i'm gonna do that just stop look i know
what i'm doing i was real lucky that my
parents were not around very much so i
didn't get much advice
so i i figured it out myself so there
was no one telling me i couldn't do it
so greenfield yeah just i was like i'm
gonna find my way through this
and since no one's telling me it's
impossible no one's telling me i can't
occasionally i would hear someone say
what are the odds i'm like listen this
[ __ ] loser
that's my thought was always like that
guy's a loser like if you think like
that you're a loser
but there are kids that make a lot of
[ __ ] money playing video games
but the thing is like you have to be
adaptable you have to be able to play
multiple video games because
the one video game that you get really
good at what are the odds that's going
to be around five years from now
you know like what's the big one now
like fortnite is that did they make
money off of that
yeah yeah and then there's a call of
duty
they make money off that what's the big
money starcraft used to be the big one
right
that league of legends counter-strike
counter-strike is a it's still the
half-life mod yeah
uh variations of it have come out but
it's still basically the same exact game
they don't make money off quick though
right
not really not really a couple one one
or two guys do i think
yeah see it's it's you got to pick the
right game
you know you could be interested you're
going to spend uh
5-10 hours a day in that you have to you
would have to
you